well heidi ho
reject nation we're here for stranger
things episode four today excited to
check this bad boy i've been loving
season four so far uh guys full length
watch along as we sync it with the time
code available for a super sexy rejects
that patreon cover a whole bunch of
shows over there where at the same tier
you also get the option for reaction
highlights included exclusively for some
of those shows if you can't do that
please leave a like and a comment that
helps us out on the algorithm very much
thank you thank you thank you and also
uh subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next stranger things episode is
up and then boys at prepper you guys are
hard at work gonna be getting this done
without y'all while we're in the middle
of moving so thank you let's get to it
what's doing these killings that's what
we're trying to ascertain in the
meantime it is a vital importance that
you do not speak to anyone about this no
no way i know this is difficult to
understand it's not difficult this is
impossible
we're friends of owens
11 trusted us
now we're asking the same from you
smoke some putt
calm down guys
it was here
a grandfather clock you've been marked
max chrissy's headache started a week
ago read six days ago i've been having
them for five days
i don't know how long i have probably
like another day looks like i'm gonna
die tomorrow
stay here
the hell was that it's probably the
janitor
they all hooked up
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry guys
i'm spiking for eight miles
wow that's an adrenaline rush
you're in terrible danger all right yeah
that definitely sucks but we've got
bigger problems than jason right now
the love of your life is gonna die and
it's what are you gonna do to save her
is lucas home negative do you know where
he is
we were supposed to go out go out i see
he's taking a step down for max
i ain't trying to kill someone right now
do you know dustin henderson know him
i've bled with him
please tell him i've been covering for
his ass for two days now each day of
covering costs 10 bucks with a dpr
that's the daily percentage rate of 7.9
percent another week of this and he's
buying me a goddamn nintendo
with duck hunt and a duck hunt gun
how did fekna get through oh and how's
it getting through now and why now and
why then just pops out in the 50s kills
one family he's like yeah i'm good poofy
just disappears just yeah like penny
wise hey it's kind of like pennywise
dude it's just like pennywise
we have a plan
thanks to nancy's newspaper minions we
are now rock star psychology students at
the university of notre dame i'm now
ruth and i'm rose ruth
she looks like a ruth yeah but for what
is essentially a ransom exchange for
that for that i think you very much need
to be
on
time in the most patriotic motel
why aren't you tense
murray's probably dreamed of making a
drop for years
all goes well
for tomorrow night you're home
eating answers with your sexy woman
she's not my mom
of course not
she saves your life because of
friendship
must be pretty for your woman he's not
my woman
hit his feet
yeah break both of his legs
you're not under arrest great
no no you're you're here to protect us
and watch tv apparently
weed withdrawals
if you keep staring at that it's not
going to change yeah you're right
well i mean you don't that's not throw
it out yeah
we never fight i mean we fought before
but just like silly fights stupid fights
but
i don't know this one just
felt more adult like it it just felt
more real like we came of age
i would say that man
looks like it's gonna be up to us again
it always is isn't it
which is why we can't stay here
oh jonathan's getting in the action yeah
buddy we make everything fresh here at
surfer boy except for our pineapple
which comes from a can but i still
highly recommend slapping some juicy
pineapple on your pot
justice for pineapple oh my god what an
answer
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh those goodbye letters
i know you guys are staring at me
sorry
why don't you guys play simon if we go
to east hawkins will this story pin hers
of course
wait why are we talking about these
talkings
[Music]
no
you know what's happening you just gotta
stop saying no to stuff
anderson
that's super wacky of yours better reach
panhars
every time he gets asked to babysit he
ends up being the worst babysitter
someone should listen to him
[Music]
i can't breathe in this thing and i'm
itchy i'm itching all over it's not all
about comfort okay we're academics who
are evidently coming straight from an
easter run
[Laughter]
to say they look like super christians
i know very
quite well actually oh good
those who get to
teach
[Laughter]
yes that's actually why we're here
i mean we can only learn so much in a
classroom
and i'm sympathetic to your struggle
julie
but there is a protocol
i'm breaking out in a rash my boobs hurt
and i'll tell you the truth anthony may
i call you anthony these aren't actually
my clothes i borrowed them because i
wanted you to take us seriously because
nobody takes girls seriously
can i tell you a story 1978 summer camp
and my counselor drew told me and
everyone in cabin see the true story of
the victor creel massacre and little
petey mchugh you know peter
[Laughter]
other kids they wanted to be astronauts
basketball players rock stars but i
wanted to be you
[Laughter]
but don't tell me that crybaby petey
mchugh wouldn't have gotten an audience
with victor in a matter of moments if
he'd asked politely because you and i
both know that he would
[Laughter]
i'm back in 30.
damn robin boom mary
you use that that over talking to your
advantage
marry you ruth
mary right
no i don't know i think maybe getting
rocky
dude these snow shots are beautiful like
you get those little particles of
snowfall you must be dicey just choice
murray
hope you do not mind if i count you two
seem very nice very trustworthy
his name was currying
you're the craziest one here hopper
nice i would stab him in the face
let's do it let's do it
rip the band-aid of all your foot skin
off
oh [ __ ]
okay
don't fire the gun don't fire the gun
whatever you do for the love of christ
nice
[Music]
oh
please
keep it indoor keep it indoors
oh my god oh ow ow
nice
oh jesus
[Applause]
oh very cool yes
oh my god he's gonna run barefoot sure
just add a little more salt to all these
wounds
god damn jesus
son of a [ __ ]
classic
hopper more like rudder
haha guys
[Music]
she got a lot of writing done i know
if she lives she should write a feature
film
she's going to have to have a lot of
awkward conversations yeah if they find
this it's just a lot
um i i left some letters inside letters
i
i don't understand what if something
happens to me
max baby nothing is going to happen to
you i know but if it did
[Music]
nothing is going to happen baby
promises
oh [ __ ] oh not now not here
whoa
wow what
a manipulator
she wasn't even helping she wasn't even
only picked the whole thing
did something happen please just go
so open up a tad bit please just a tad
bit they might need the clues yeah for
when stuff happens to them so excited
to speak with victor
preferably as she said
alone
now you guys are coming across like
groupies
cultists
yes
why not
you've caught me in a rebellious mood
and there's something rather urgent i
need to check on any
he's gonna call professor brentwood yep
yep yeah professor branbox
well hello clarice and
clarisse
clary sees
you got visitors
real pretty ones
oh yeah don't do that bad don't do that
i'm half expecting one of those nails to
just come right off stop you're pissing
me off
cut it out man
i don't talk to reporters whatever
killed your family
we think it's back
oh no
whatever it is i
i think we should work together i think
it'll be easier for we're a team
friends
that's
will's been looking for that
waiting for you i look for you my
way to hear these words for two whole
seasons
hello there
whoa
oh my god
stay here
what's a what a rude awakening jesus
christ
what's going on
we gotta go
what the hell is going on
now it's found footage
[Music]
damn you're good at your job my dude is
competent jesus
never
what is the water golf again
he is taking out the military right now
one man wrecking machine
it's the mustache
oh oh you
knew this was coming pete my cop just
earned my respect by a million percent
yep
[Music]
guess that lady at the top was telling
the truth
that was quite a wonder
how about 39 980
so uh no deal let's recap
naruto run hopper
huh
he never discovered the demogorgon no
not once maybe they'll have to go back
haunting religious 80s music
[Music]
i wonder how much they paid for it not
to be skippy
[Music]
he ratted them out
oh
no
you son of a [ __ ]
oh my god you gotta be kidding me
[Music]
oh the guard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
no
oh damn it no [ __ ]
man this season is something else yep it
is so intense
wow
this is amazing
it looks like a fairy tale
a dream yeah a grim fairy tale
we had one
month of peace in that house
and then it began
always what did the animals do
was
the spawn of satan
[Music]
first it canceled the water building
oh my god yep yep yep i began to have
encounters of my own
[Music]
they hate that music nothing scarier
than pleasant oldies
wow
it took virginia first
[Music]
oh my god that is horrific
only to find myself
in a nightmare for our worse
[Music]
oh boy
why vac now let him live he clearly had
so much guilt if you can even hear this
[Music]
they really hope that you can
the clouds are changing
i'm so so sorry billy
i love your shitty little sister
max
look at the clouds yeah
oh damn
this guy's like freaking vincent price
max
time to giddy up yeah
max
max
[Laughter]
that wanted me to die that day really no
it's not true that's why you stood there
isn't it
god the church bell
it is time
oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
hatch said that music can reach parts of
the brain that words can't so maybe
that's the key a lifeline a lifeline
back to reality oh my god play some
music for max yeah
keep talking
dustin it's robin
holy [ __ ] finally please please please
tell me you guys have been figured out
ella fitzgerald
oh
man
[Music]
no myers
meyer's grave
[Music]
oh
no
god it's like some sam raimi's [ __ ]
what is this her song what's your
favorite song why robbie said if you
listen it's so much to explain right now
what's her favorite song
[Music]
this is for some kind of ritual
[Applause]
oh my god guys
oh good song choice too
[Music]
spit in his face
[Music]
[Music]
no
i don't want a letter
we're right here i'm right here
[Music]
oh yeah
oh
jesus
[Music]
run up that hill damn it
come on
[Music]
you [ __ ] show
you
thank you oh [ __ ]
oh most satisfying not cut to credits
ever
great reprise beautiful shot good job
sean lovey
confirming
you're a bully wagner clown clown you're
a clown you're clown clown you're
bullied
clown
god i'm exhausted
[ __ ]
i thought they were gonna do some
classic stranger things
like let's let's let them tune in to the
next episode yeah i've come this far
don't do it
i like that the episode actually does
just end
with that little bit like that was very
i think self-aware choice on their part
but i appreciated it
who daddy oh buddy or something all
right
got a few more episodes to get through
here so
ah yeah we'll keep it short
the best weekend
we always
say uh this is i don't
i have no idea what that actress's name
is still
sadie sync yeah he plays max
yeah yeah
she's uh she's incredible she's
fantastic yeah an incredible former
beautiful monologue
and it's so real it's like such a real
performer plays that repressed
personality difficult to open up
character so well so so realistic
and uh yeah you do some [ __ ] of of love
and hope saving the day you're gonna get
me man
you're just gonna freaking get me right
there
anytime someone is like in a desperate
dash to just get back to the people they
love and have just now learned again to
appreciate
like oh
yeah
man i like i like when when uh like an
action scene or some kind of set piece
can also get me very emotional
like when the story really does collide
with the action in a very visceral way
yes and it it they they make a powerful
there's so much emphasis on music this
season in a different context
like it's a part of the before it was
like part of the personality of the show
embodying the 80s
and
this really just feels like a horror
show now and not you know
the 80s nostalgia show at all yeah the
80s wonder show yeah yeah and you know
like billy being in a band and not billy
um uh danny
well who's the freaking guy dungeons and
dragons guy danny his name freddy freddy
that's danny is it freddy freddy i think
confident about that
i'm pretty sure it's not danny
is there another danny in the show
i'm not sure what were you gonna say
i'll look it up
you might be right i think it's freddy
the freak yes
um with him being in a band and then
also
this emphasis on music channeling a
different part of your brain and i think
that's something a lot of us can relate
to hence
why
slapping 80s music onto a show taking
place in the easy so nostalgic and you
talk about the soundtrack so there's a
bit of like this interesting meta
commentary about that with dealing with
the psychology of why nostalgic how to
work so well
and then especially for stranger things
a show that was so popular and one of
the biggest talks about it was it was so
nostalgic for the 80s and then using a
song to help save the day
capturing that part in your brain
activating it is a big and leading to
this uh action of love and hope during a
time of such great harrowing
um
just like beautiful harrowing visuals by
the way that was like absolutely
beautiful at the same time as
nightmarish as it was as it's like
messed up as it was it's still
beautiful to behold and i think it's
cool that they managed to there's not
been anything about have fun 80s song
it's it did the music using that as a
part of
the actual character for your show is
great great choice uh all around and
this is it just gets more horror as it
descends
with horror genre tropes of the
supernatural
haunting and but then it also felt most
stranger things horror here because it's
almost like we're in the upside down
than before yeah yeah yeah absolutely
and i thought running running up that
hill and especially using like the
the kate bush version and all that stuff
like i thought that was a really nicely
chosen song because
you know i feel like there are always
debates to be had about
deliberate use of music and when lyrics
reflect too heavily of what the plot is
doing but i thought that was a well
song for just all her character beats
because
it definitely sinks over and lines up
with both
uh you know her wishing she could have
swapped places with billy but also just
that you know
again the motif of literally running up
some kind of you know obstacle
uh and just the fact that that is an
iconic song like i could see how that
would be somebody's favorite song
at the time
and uh yeah i thought it was a really
nice thematic choice in a really great
way like you said to build upon
the you know motifs and the language of
the show and then make that stuff more
meaningful
and uh and yeah and i thought it was a
really nicely uh
i thought it was really nice the way
they orchestrated that as part of the
solution or as part of the way we can
fight back against vector like it felt
like a very natural unfolding of that
and using the motif of okay we're in his
flashback and uh you know ella
fitzgerald is playing and so that's the
sort of clue
and uh going back through that too like
the whole flashback with creel and
getting like you said like a little
american horror story-esque interlude
where you're in the past and you're
seeing the onset of at least the first
time we're aware of this having happened
you know recently
and uh i thought he turned in a great
performance too like he basically gets
to give this big old monologue that is
then filled in with some
cutaways and such but you know it's like
vecna itself is such a monstrous
presence and is that are we to assume
that's robert england doing the voice of
becna
yeah we established that since the first
episode oh i guess so i just wasn't 100
certain
but uh either way i mean i i thought
that uh
that yeah like having him in a subtle
way he's got the bigger hand on the one
side with the claws there's like that
little subtle freddie nod but this also
reminds you of just how good of an actor
robert england can be and how affecting
he can be
and uh you know is he also creel
he's cruel yeah yeah yeah well that's
why i was asking because i was like okay
i can definitely tell oh i thought they
were asking about vector yeah no that's
yeah cause vecna i'm like okay he must
be doing the voice but i don't think
he's in the makeup unless he is in the
middle no they did establish that he
would be um
i think they they i think the duffer
brothers um
said that he would be creel yeah yeah
absolutely but i didn't know if he was
the voice of the yeah the monster uh as
well to play a human they cover up his
eyes i know
but i mean even still that was a great
as it is a really good looking effect
and he really was able to emote through
that and i love the tension that they
got out of that whole sequence because
you get the fun and games of them having
to break in and ingratiate themselves
and then yeah you get your silence of
the lambs sort of
you know unnerving interlude with him uh
and yeah there's the way that that
progresses while filling in the blanks i
thought was really well done too it's so
tension this is like the most intense
season it is so intense
uh yeah i really love it and i think
that there's like such great little
subtleties that are i think are
fantastic
you know even when mike and will will
looking up at
mike as mike is feeling a little bit
more like the mic that we've all come to
love
a softer mic not just complaining mike
but a softer mic yeah
and
will just
always been such a lost soul and he
always found like a sense of ground and
feeling grounded with his friends yeah
you know and being in this new state
we're still feeling a bit like an
outsider or not in his place of comfort
you know the part where he felt he most
belonged and felt safe was with his
friends
and to have mike you know confide in him
and tell him like we can do this
together just feeling like this is where
i belong it's really a touching moment
or even lucas and all these times of him
trying to get max to connect to him and
seeing like you can talk to me and
sometimes it could be like a little bit
desperate but then you see in this
moment that if it wasn't for lucas being
there knowing max so well to be able to
find the song choice
to help save her like he does know and
love her and then protects her i think
the way they write
that whole grieving thing because
like i really like the monologue max is
giving when she's reading the letter
yeah
uh
and then i i did find my mind kind of
trailing off a little bit a couple
points though going
i remember this billy guy being a
complete abusive [ __ ] to you and
there was that whole thing in season two
where you like uh uh you you drugged him
i mean when he was like beating up steve
you told him not to mess with you again
throwing him in the bat he was like a
total dick yeah you know and and and
it's so
and then he was the villain he granted
he was being embodied uh by uh upside
down thinking magic my player uh yeah
he was
yeah so
what i appreciated was that they really
painted the gray of what it's like to
lose someone who is abusive to you who
is also family
of
you do have the good memories and you do
have the wishful things you do have i i
imagine we could have had this and that
and it could have been beautiful but
then what he's praying on is the other
side that can really make you feel
guilty which is
i'm kind of relieved that you died
because you were awful you know you
can't hurt me anymore yeah
yeah and
i thought that was such a a great way to
flesh out her grief you know
because it's not like she's confessing
and saying goodbye and trying to really
put this to rest with her letter it's oh
it's all this other stuff she's not
acknowledging that he can feed off of
because that's a hard thing to admit uh
when you're like i'm kind of relieved my
brother died
when you know it's like we know that
yeah
billy was messed up yeah
um and knew how to make her feel bad
always like especially in season two
their relationship he was insanely
abusive yeah so
uh
yeah maybe bill was a great character
like dr montgomery was freaking awesome
to have his presence back was nice yeah
every little cameo yeah um so yeah i
thought it was great and they had a
great action scene too with the with the
go with the runner yeah the one with
that i was like where did this cool
scene come from
like this coffee is just a joke i'm like
you're badass you're taking out the
whole military yeah yeah yeah you're
thinking about all these soldiers yeah
no i mean netflix you know obviously
it's like a meme about their shows but i
thought that was another one of like wow
you really stepped up for this one like
it yeah as much as it is easy to go like
ah netflix wonder it was a really
impressive and really visceral and
intense sequence and yeah it's nice to
get uh maybe jonathan being a little
more important yeah he's the one who's
initiated that yeah yeah
and this is also except for flashbacks a
a a nearly 11-less episode right we
don't even check in with her in the
present once now in some ways this is
like their walking dead or game of
thrones season where you just like yes
don't check it with other characters
that's absolutely a good call and then
friggin a i mean everything with joyce
and murray and and yuri and and the
double cross i mean i guess we we could
have
done them
i know i did i didn't either like i kept
i couldn't see that i kept every step of
the way i kept being like okay it's
gonna be this thing or there won't be
enough money or something like that and
then yeah just comes right down to the
double cross so uh
i don't know that's easy that that
situation only seems like it can get
crazier and more complicated well it's
interesting they kept things like
a little bit fun despite inspire despite
some stuff that was occasionally
horrific with the you know the dream
sequences with becca with max
they kept a lot of it fun because these
episodes are so thick yeah so there's
they structure them differently than
before
um
it's fun and then you come back to
russia with hopper that's when it's
really like realistic and intense you
feel the biting like there's no there's
no real stranger things going on over
there yeah you know
in terms of
sci-fi stuff that's why i keep going
what about the demogorgon you know isn't
there a big demogorgon maybe that's
where they would escape prisoners and
corrupt guards i was thinking
so yeah you have that and then the way
they are tying it into the events like
they had the russians in season all
throughout season three
but this time they're actually scary
well yeah right and and yeah and and the
even joyce's involvement and murray's
involvement have ramifications from that
previous season because clearly the kgb
is very much aware of them a thousand
percent yeah
and uh the way to build on that and you
know i did think hopper would get away
that was also a good fight scene too
yeah i thought hopper was going to get
away and they they sell you on it like
oh he can finally relax he puts his feet
under the blanket eats the peanut butter
he feels relieved yeah oh it's like
suffering sobbing into peanut butter
only yeah to get apprehended immediately
yeah i mean i feel like the guards would
have thought that through why did the
warden call him
the yuri why the warden called yuri
he said the warden called me or did he
call the warden he called yeah yeah he
called the warden yeah he just said
don't call here yeah yuri called yuri
called the warden well he called that oh
yeah but yuri called the warden
beforehand to let him know that uh our
guy is corrupt and is helping hopper i
think he reported i thought he said the
warding called him
uh maybe but the i don't know the way i
took that scene was he said i called the
warden and ratted on you to make the
money for ratting on you i gotta know
this
i gotta know i'm pretty sure he said the
warding called me all right check it i
must know not to prove you wrong or
something john just i feel like it
changes the context a lot in that scene
eddie munson it's not freddie it's eddie
munson eddie here we go
we can verify that and then we can
verify this don't worry someone already
put down a comment correcting us yes
eddie munson
yeah that's the way it goes man
let me
just speed through this i'm very sorry i
just thought you should the
side changing plan come on
speeding this up
oh i just got the phone with the board a
very productive call okay so so yeah he
just snitched on him
bastard yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] a
i trusted the corrupt guy to have a good
corrupt liaison
i mean i imagine that they would
i mean you guys probably finished the
show it's not week to week yeah don't i
mean it so it won't matter if you
comment because we'll probably be past
this point anyway i mean i'll i'll say
this that i think the trailers did ruin
something then
ah okay because you do see
yeah
yeah
trying to damn try not to think too hard
it wasn't even no i just remember that i
remember because yeah
do we see him back
i mean we see murray and joyce on a
plane
okay kind of intensely oh so they're
probably going to overpower yuri damn
uh
that sucks wasn't like a leak yeah
that's all right that's just like the
trailer
yeah
there's other shots with hopper that i
that are coming to mind that they were
like big in the promos in the beginning
that have not come to fruition yeah
that's just funny about me is like
movies that can weirdly handle spoilers
now and leaks i don't like actively seek
them but if it happens like i don't know
um if the movie is good enough the
moment will hit but a show
is i'm way more particular about a show
for some reason a show because it's a
longer investment a bigger investment
yeah especially this season yeah
i'd rather not know with a show yeah
yeah 100 yeah yeah um that that's
something that weirdly irks me a lot
that irks me a lot more i i like oh just
keep it away from me i don't want to
yeah
um
but
uh this is another great episode uh
thank you guys so much for being here
and
i don't know what day of the week this
is that this is going up should we just
do the rest of the patron call-outs sure
let's shout out some patrons yeah
fan pops always getting chased by the
cops olivia del guy sharing french fries
with me andy funk is never in a skunk
the lorenzo baxter foundation
corporation read richard this is a
fantastic form why are you here
differently sane what is it that you
have to gain
that's the heavenly smell of levitt
odell
somehow finding our patreon she charted
a course as she ventured on her lauren
american horse i could never be jaded
when i'm hanging with simply faded i
never say no no to peter pacheco co
you're the one from me joanna saint
louis let's climb a tree
you know what makes me feel free when i
hang out with mr ro cree we want to
fight like jackie chan and bruce lee
knock me to the floor getting picked up
by sj90
justin martin always showing up here
angry like cartman
rosie beatty is not a nosy lady she's
she's lovely and you should get to know
phillip j smith jr always kicking it
with all these boomers he jumped into
puberty a little bit late call him a
late bloomer speaking of calling i'm
calling the punk calling to call me
backpack jen smith don't know what
rhymes
melanie leblanc
on getting cronk that's right
badonka talk turn your phone
notifications off jason dolan when are
you and i gonna go bowling when i put my
finger inside of you we call that hole
we do call it holland and uh we would
love to be holland all
of you
thank you guys so much for being here
we love you we appreciate your support
every month
and for sticking with us through this
nonsense we'll see you guys soon
[Music]